good morning this video is going to be
mostly for citizens of the united states
of america i know that's not all of
nerdfighteria but we got some important
things going on here we live in a
country where we decide on stuff
together we decide who the president is
going to be who the lawmakers are going
to be in many cases what the laws are
going to be attorney generals
attorney generals and judges and
sheriffs and ballot initiatives
we vote for these things we tend to
focus and i'm including myself in this a
lot on the president but there are a
great number of things on our ballots
every time we vote
and those things have huge impacts on
our country our state and our cities and
counties a huge amount of how america
gets governed is on the
state and local levels and here's the
thing that i worry about if you don't
think about it before november 3rd you
go into the ballot box
or you're about to mail in your ballot
and you think i haven't really done the
research
so maybe i just won't and the first
thing i'll say to that is you don't have
to vote for everything on a ballot this
is not a test
but the second thing is you gotta vote
if you don't go your voice doesn't get
heard
and your opinions they matter less
elected leaders listen to voters more
than they listen
to the average american this is because
voters are the ones who hire them
they should be representing all
americans equally yes but let's be
honest
you're going to be more responsive to
the people who are doing the hiring and
firing so turn yourself into a voter
that's how you get served how do you
turn yourself into a voter well first
thing you got to make sure that you're
registered you can go to vote.org and
check it takes 15 seconds
second if you are registered or you need
to get registered you need to learn how
all this works
in your state and in the u.s elections
are administered state by state and so
there are different rules for every
state which is why
we at complexly in partnership with
media wise have created
how to vote in every state it's a
collection of videos it represents every
state and also some
non-state situations like military
overseas or
territories and it'll get you straight
on everything from absentee voting to
sample ballots to getting registered
every one of these videos is less than
three minutes long
and it will give you everything you need
to know to create your voting plan and
this is the thing
when you sit down to watch one of these
videos i want you to do it with a pen
and a piece of paper and i want you to
write down your voting plan everything
from what date you're going to be
registered by
when you're going to need to know who
and what you're voting for and how
you're going to either get your mail-in
ballot or vote early or
be at the polls on november 3rd i
remember when i was first voting a big
question i had because i was in college
was
do i vote where i am in college or do i
vote
where i am like my parents house this is
an important thing to understand about
voting
what you vote for depends on where you
live and that depends on where you are
registered in the situation i was in i
could either choose to be registered
where i was going to college or at my
parents house i chose at my parents
house but the address you're registered
at determines
all of the elections you will be voting
in like obviously if i was registered in
saint petersburg i wouldn't be voting
for the mayor of orlando
other things to understand mail and
voting absentee voting depends
a lot state by state some places
everybody can do it without a need to do
it other places you have to fulfill
requirements
early voting also happens at different
times in different places and the way
that sample ballots are given out also
changes from place to place sample
ballots are super useful they let you
know exactly what's going to be on your
ballot you can even fill it out
at home and then bring it to the polls
with you voting is an opportunity there
are lots of places
in this world where people don't get to
do it it's also a responsibility it's
also maybe a little stressful but how to
vote in every state
has all of the information available to
you and it doesn't take a ton of time to
get that information in your head
they've also made a few other helpful
videos like how to do your research how
to understand polls
how to watch a political ad it's a
really great tool i'm really proud that
we're a part of it
so watch your state and then you can
send that to all the other people you
know
so that they can know how easy it is and
important it is to vote three minutes
and you're set because i don't want to
know what happens
if you don't go john i'll see you on
tuesday